for days a 40-mile military convoy had
stalled outside kiev
but images taken in the last 24 hours
suggest russian troops have reorganized
u.s satellite company maxar says
vehicles appear to have dispersed and
redeployed
with towed artillery now in firing
positions nearby
it comes as a senior u.s defense
official said russian troops have
advanced on the capital
while the information war escalates over
whether a chemical weapons attack is
being planned
no chemical or any other weapons of mass
destruction were developed on my land
and if you do something like that
against us you will get the most severe
sanctions response
the scenes of a bombed maternity
hospital in mariopol suggests there are
no boundaries to russia's barbarism
the concern now is a chemical attack
russia has called a meeting of the un
security council later to discuss
unsubstantiated claims ukraine is
housing biological weapons
but the us has warned this is a ploy by
russia to create a pretext to deploy
such weapons itself
with no desire for nato military
involvement it seems the west's warnings
about red lines fall largely on deaf
ears in moscow
there is strong evidence that we are
seeing
war crimes taking place and we need to
take that evidence and record that
evidence we are working uh to
collate the evidence on the ground of
what is happening to make sure that
putin
and his associates are held to account
for these appalling actions
the question is how to stop this now
ukrainians grieving their loved ones and
life as they knew it
police sergeant roman
buried by his wife and three young
children
to the sound of defiant song
but in some of the worst bombed areas
there's no dignity of a funeral and no
way to escape this fighting
sally lockwood sky news